when did text messaging begin wow the
day December 3rd 1992. oh look at this
1984. the SMS concept was first
developed in the franco-german
corporation the first telephone call uh
what were the first words ever spoken on
the telephone call they were by
Alexander Graham Bell invento the
telephone when he made the first call on
March 10 1876 100 years before I was
born Jay's assistant Thomas Watson Mr
Watson come here I want to see you what
would you have said I would have been
like Deez Nuts these are all guys that
get the credit when they're not really
deserving of all the credit I mean
they've they're deserving of
contributions but
like you on this podcast
you're throwing bows you you started it
I didn't start [__] today get started I
didn't start where did I start you were
getting salty
where did I start that's salty